[Music]
welcome to sugar lab we're in the arts
district in downtown los angeles i'm
kyle von hassling i'm meegan bozeman i'm
william hoo and we're co-founders of
sugar lab and we create 3d printed food
experiences we created sugar lab over 10
years ago when we invented a new kind of
3d printer that prints with dehydrated
food powders it's been our brainchild
since then our labor of love and we're
proud to share it now we 3d print with
real food everything that we print with
is something this chef would source and
it's all edible and safe to eat 3d
printing with food is incredible because
it does a couple things really really
well it creates food in incredible
precision we 3d print with a lot of
geometric corners and symmetry that
aren't able to be done by hand you can
do things with 3d printed food that
complement traditional but also do
things that are not even possible one of
the challenges with 3d printed food is
that people have never had it before
it's been a fun challenge to figure out
what we should offer to people all right
now let's go upstairs to check out the
design process
so this is the strawberry bonbon we
sketched it out first and now i'm just
roughing out the shape of it and then
now i'm going to start placing the seeds
and we can do this really precisely on
the software we love that our food can
look like the actual food that we're
designing and also we can play off that
by changing the whole experience of
actually eating that fruit and that's
important to us because this is already
a new product and we wanted to make it
super familiar but also change that
experience which people won't really
expecting and now we have a kitchen out
here where chef victoria does her magic
hi my name is victoria rose johnson i am
the kitchen manager and resident pastry
chef here i have so much fun i get to
make incredible things and beautiful
things of that when i was younger i used
to love bacon cakes and that led to me
going to the culinary institute of
america i landed here and now this is
what i get to do
i have always been interested in the
decorating aspect and there are
limitations when it comes to making
things out of fondant and buttercream
but there are no limitations here and
it's absolutely amazing one of my
favorites is our love and hex potions
these are glitter bombs which are
absolutely amazing the process for
printing it absolutely has to begin with
measuring out all of your ingredients
what i'm about to make is our kimchi
bouillon one of our savory items that we
make i'm going to start with our neutral
powder this is the one that doesn't have
any additional flavor it basically
tastes very similar to powdered sugar
next i know this looks exactly the same
but it is actually our lime powder one
of my favorite parts is our beautiful
beautiful gochugaru we have to make it
super super fine so that there's no
chance that the particle size is too big
it could fail a print if the particle
size were too big or it wouldn't spread
right in the printer which of course
is no fun for anybody next here i have
the celery salt that helps bring in that
green flavor that you you aren't going
to get with powdered sugar and then last
but not least is our regular salt again
refined super super fine all of those
get mixed into a big bowl that then gets
brought over to the printer when we're
ready to sift into the printer i start
by finding the correct file on the
little computer that's attached to the
printer i make sure i heighten the feed
in the build bed now the feed bed is
where the powder is going to go before
it starts printing and the build bed is
where the powder is going to end up it
moves from one to the other and that's
that's basically part of the printing
process so i will pull it up right here
and i will get these to their right
heights and then we're ready to go it is
a weird feeling that most of my job as a
chef is playing with technology and yes
it is always this messy after i have
everything sifted in i gotta make sure
that all those little loose particles
that got around the edges get into the
print itself now we gotta grab the
tamper i like doing the little tap at
the end to get all of the excess off now
we're going to have to smooth this guy
out so let's bring these up to the right
height this is going to pull the powder
across and make that really nice flat
top so that we have a good printing base
and of course while the base itself is a
sugar mixture it gets bound with a
water-based ink similar to how you would
use food coloring and other things and
there she is flat beautiful and ready
for printing
when i go to excavate i essentially push
down the feed bed which is where the
powder came from and i push up the build
bed just a little bit so i have access
to the parts next i just grab them so we
of course really really carefully pull
them out and we set them up on these
little trays here so this blue is going
to come out really really gorgeous when
we do powder which is a fun little
machine it's extremely loud which is
really convenient for singing songs when
i'm alone in the kitchen
it is not however convenient when i'm
singing songs really loud in the kitchen
and don't hear my co-workers walk
through the door
they're all ready to go after that these
have a nice neutral flavor and they are
blue toned it's not the only color that
we do we also do an orange ombre as well
as some other beautiful rainbow cubes
these are most commonly used in tea or
coffee anything you want just a little
bit sweeter neutral is not the only
flavor we make we also do things like
watermelon lemonade and lime we do
things as crazy as mexican hot chocolate
and cinnamon
not as sweet as i thought it would be
which is really nice i think it's like a
refreshing level of sweetness
so these are the strawberry covered
chocolate truffles they have an
incredible ginger shell the red one is
filled with a caramelized honey and
chili then we also have the pink one
here which is a tamarind elderflower and
then the last one here is our white one
and it is a pineapple upside down cake
these are some of my favorites they're
the original recipes that we made very
very very beginning i am getting ready
to fill here i've got my ganache i've
got my little truffles over here we make
a ton of different truffles the flavor i
have here is tamarind elderflower all of
the ganache gets made in-house each one
of these is hand filled by me cheers
mmm
you guys have to try this the shell
every time i think it's gonna break my
teeth it doesn't it's so soft got the
perfect bite oddly enough our best
seller is one of our savory items that
we make and it is our kimchi bouillon
which is an absolutely wonderful recipe
that we make that ends up tasting like
kimchi and you can put it in your ramen
there's a million different things you
can do with it so it's both surprising
and not surprising that it's our top
seller
it tastes like
elevated cup noodles there's so many
great memories over the course of the
last decade with sugar lab we've had a
ton of really special projects that came
to us from excited chefs who want to
make something super custom or even just
from people all across the country or
who are hosting birthday parties get
togethers we have a custom wedding line
we also make cake toppers for weddings
and they're super cool we work with
bakers locally here in la one of the
really neat things we can do is 3d scan
a bride or groom and render them in 3d
and then 3d print it directly into sugar
and you have your own likeness in the 3d
printed sugar it's made from our friends
over at action face they have an iphone
app you download it and 3d scan yourself
and then send us the file and we get it
3d printed speaking of figurines we made
one of you jasmine oh my gosh
it's me
this is the coolest thing i've ever seen
let's eat it cheers
[Music]
mmm
it tastes like cake with the texture of
meringue this is crazy all that hard
work the printer did and i'm just eating
it this is the neutral one so it tastes
like sugar and it's really nicely
flavored at the end of the day we all
love food and we wanted 3d printed food
to be a part of everyone's life
[Music]
[Music]
you